[Applause]
today i'm going to introduce you to the
art of discipline opportunism
so sit back relax and enjoy
as we take off on a flight of
self-discovery
i'm honored to be the protagonist of a
stanford mba case study
entitled sadiq gilani's airline career
takes off
this is part of jeffrey feffer's path to
power class
in discussions with the class professor
pfeffer came up with the term discipline
opportunism
to summarize my approach to spot and
pursue
exciting opportunities
through reflecting on my life
experiences and learnings i develop this
art into a five-part framework
which will also help your career reach
cruising altitude
i will also give practical advice on
pursuing a portfolio career
and just like we're flying if you want
to reach cruising altitude which is the
most efficient part of the flight
you need to know where you're heading be
well prepared
then pursue your target and if necessary
pivot in the event of turbulence
i'm going to be sharing with you the
tips i've learned which you can apply in
your lives today
this framework can also be applied to an
industry and in the second half of my
talk
i will share with you how i expect the
travel and airline industry
to evolve postcovid
so the story begins with the birth with
my birth in inner city london
to a single mother from trinidad tobago
and an absent father from pakistan
who met after immigrating to london
from an early age i was fascinated by
flying
and we would travel to trinidad every
summer with my mother to visit family
my mother would always inspire me with
these words throughout my childhood
good better best never let it rest until
your good is better
and your better best
she came to london in 1960s to train as
a nurse and wanted her only child to
have the education
which she was never able to
she gave birth a week before her 42nd
birthday
and worked hard to provide for us it was
her dream for me to study at cambridge
and she was incredibly proud when i
graduated with two first
first class degrees and was even
featured in the university prospectus
i learned in my youth that i had to
stand out to fit in
and be accepted just like
with many insecure overachievers and i'm
sure there are many here
consulting firms are natural extension
mostly hiring these types
and getting the most out of us through
playing to our insecurities
through the fear of up or out
i was lucky to be applying for graduate
jobs in the peak of the dotcom bubble in
the year 2000
although i received just one job offer
so i joined brain company in london and
the consulting toolkit provided me with
a great foundation
after two and a half years working in
london
i moved to johannesburg for a transfer
i was really inspired my colleagues to
do an mba and was lucky to be accepted
at harvard
and expected to return home to london
just after that
17 00 years later i've yet to return
back to london
my mba experience was transformational
and confirmed my passion for aviation
after graduating i joined a group of
ex-baineys at a new boutique aviation
consulting firm
where i would have the chance to focus
only on airlines and help grow the
business from 10 to 60 consultants
i had the chance to first of all be
based in sydney for two years
and then moved to new york for two years
after working as a partner i decided to
move to brazil
to join a low-cost airline preparing for
an ipo as the chief commercial officer
however the ipo was called off within a
year and the airline was sold so i
decided to look for an airline role back
in europe
i joined lufthansa and sent spent seven
years living in germany
then most recently two and a half years
ago i moved to dubai to join emirates
so it's quite the journey and during
this time
it provided me the opportunity to visit
124 countries
which you can see shaded in red
my big moment came when i received my
offer to join lufthansa
as chief strategy officer at the age of
32 as their youngest ever senior vice
president
at the time this was my dream job
the new ceo christopher franz valued my
international experience and strong
education
and saw me not speaking german as a
chance to make the
more the company more international and
change the culture
until that point it was rare for anyone
to join on a senior role from outside
the company
i remember my first meeting of the top
50 executives looking around the room
and seeing 45 german men over the age of
50.
they were being forced to speak english
in that round for the first time just
for me
i remember my boss joe shotland saying
to me
your chief strategy officer role is a
platform think about how you use it
so during this time i was able to join
the world economic forum's global agenda
council for travel
start an mba class at stanford get on
the board of three
subsidiaries of lufthansa and deliver a
ted talk
during that time i also worked on the
strategy for developing the low-cost
segment of the lufthansa group
and became one of the first employees
into the new pan-european low-cost
subsidiary
eurowings
i will now share with you the tools of
disciplined opportunism
that i learned that helped me fast-track
my career and land these opportunities
using the 5p framework of purpose
prepare
pursue partner and pivot
we'll discuss being clear on your
purpose how to prepare yourself and
create opportunities to arise
i will share some tips on pursuing
opportunities
we'll talk about the importance of
partners and your personal advisory
board
and then we'll discuss pivoting in the
face of setbacks
i'll show you how to apply the five
piece to your life to help you reach
cruising altitude
so let's start with purpose
dr joe despenser a neuroscientist and
author has researched the impact
on the mind of visioning your future in
contrast to living in the negative
experiences of the past
the body will start acting as if the
vision is already happening and
opportunities will come to you
carl jung also wrote about synchronicity
that opportunities come up if you set
the intention
and what i believe is in order to
achieve your long-sighted vision
you need to have short-sighted focus so
it's combining both
i'm going to show you how i set out a
north star vision
and applied short-sighted focus to
identify opportunities within reach to
support that vision
i've always been passionate about travel
and decided to make my profession my
passion
it really helped me to articulate my own
personal vision in the hbs portrait
project
where a handful of students are selected
each year to publish what they want to
do
with their one wild and precious life
in my personal mission statement i said
that i'm going to apply my energy to
help transform the airline industry
to enable others to share in the beauty
of travel
this was a refined version of what i had
outlined in my hbs
mba admissions application
and i was able to develop my personal
airline brand during my mba
when i started at harvard i had zero
airline experience
but i took the chance to cross register
at mit for two airline classes
i invited airline ceos to come and speak
i worked for two
startup airlines so by the end everyone
knew me as the airline guy
so i became a focal point for the other
mba students interested in travel
energy attracts energy so be a magnet
i also outlined in my portrait project
that i wanted to be a role model to
other minority groups and inspire them
i've addressed thousands of students
through diversity conferences
and visited high schools to share my
story
so it starts with having passion and
focus it could be
an industry such as the airline industry
it could be a function like marketing
or it could be a transformational theme
for example ai
within an industry hot topics will
emerge such as digital
or the future of travel postcovid and
i've immersed myself in these topics
there is a natural energy flow and
interest around these topics
i decided to go to a boutique airline
consulting firm rather than back to bain
because it was closer to my purpose
so as part of this reunion reflect on
your purpose
ask yourself now how easy would it be
for your classmates
to describe your purpose in just a few
words
so the second p is prepare creating the
space and knowledge to be able to pursue
your
purpose as well as looking after your
body
to start there's a quote here from
seneca
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
so first create the space
i freed up my time through ruthless 80
20 efficiency
focusing on the most important tasks
which have impact i always say with my
teams any piece of work
has a one has a one week answer or a one
day answer
work will fill that space so i time
block my assignments and complete them
one at a time
i develop the blank slides story outline
for presentations
and then reused templates which saves me
time
it requires efficient planning and
execution and for example i use the rule
of one touch
if i receive an email i get a task i try
to do it with one touch
this meant that i didn't work late hours
often but i worked very efficiently
and since my side actors are aligned to
my passion it never felt like extra work
when i was doing them
but i was willing to step up to deliver
surge capacity
and sprint when needed you need to have
work-life balance to provide the mental
bandwidth to be able to be creative
and to be able to pursue these ideas
it also helps to prepare and train your
team make your expectations clear
share with them your personal user guide
with every team i've worked in i
personally delivered training content
through bootcamps
weekly training sessions on the tools
which i've learned
it makes it much easier to delegate and
empower your team
also through providing regular feedback
i've also learned that the best way to
learn something is to share it with
others
we are lucky to be born in a time when
we have so much
access to information and knowledge
online
we're all talking about machine learning
but human learning has been
built on the collective knowledge of
over 100 billion people who have lived
on this planet
which we are uniquely able to access now
i give you a quote from me before you
chase the sun
prepare yourself with the works of carl
jung
worked extensively extensively with an
executive coach
to apply jung's tools to myself and my
work
let me give you a flavor of some of this
so when it comes to inner development we
start by looking at the self
and 90 of the mind is the subconscious
mind only 10 is your conscious mind
and in that conscious mind is your ego
and that is what you present to the out
of the world
but 90 of the world of your inner world
is the unconscious mind
and that's where complexes and your
shadow can be
can be a driver
daniel kahneman also talked about system
one versus system two
which was talking a lot about biases
which are playing out in the shadow
this has helped me to work on myself
another useful framework from jung is
type psychology
you'll know the terms intraverse
introversion versus extroversion
and this is how we process either
outside or inside
now this framework has also been
developed into myers-briggs today but
the original
tools came from carl jung and the
other important dimensions are thinking
versus feeling so making decisions
with your mind or with your emotions and
with your heart
and it also talks about how we gather
information for
using sensation gathering facts and
figures versus intuition which is
connecting the dots and seeing the big
picture
for me naturally i'm more of a thinking
type and more sensate
over time i've now learned to tap more
into my feeding function and my
into my intuition it's like developing
more muscles so working with two arms
and two legs to be more balanced
this has helped me understand my
complexes and my shadow
as well as understand other people
now it's just it's not just inner
knowledge and inner development it's
also your body
it's important that your body is well
paired in terms of nutrition and fitness
aircraft go through rigorous maintenance
programs
to ensure safety and longevity
but there's cultural pressure to keep
pushing ourselves to ignore the physical
needs of our bodies
which invariably leads to burnout
i personally make sure to get eight
hours sleep a night go to the gym three
times a week
and i'm focused on healthy eating which
means when i walk around the stanford
campus
people think i'm still an mba student
listen to your body look how it reacts
to different food types
i also practice regular meditation and
yoga
i personally love yoga it's good for the
mind and the body
so why not stretch yourself
reuni's also a great time for a
reflection so ask yourself right now
how satisfied are you with your sleep
with your fitness with your nutrition
with your time for learning and your
work-life balance
the better prepared your body and mind
are the more easily
you'll be able to pursue your purpose
which takes us to the third p pursue
which is all about how to go about
pursuing opportunities
i'm going to share with you now three
things which helped me in building my
career portfolio
that's being global in my search for
opportunities
it's about creating opportunities and
it's about filling the void in companies
but it's also important to bear in mind
learn how to be happy with what you have
whilst you pursue all that you want
so let's start with going global
so where do you think most of the alumni
on this
call where do you think most of you live
actually 43 of you
are living in california
dean paul oyer says when searching for
jobs or a partner
thick markets produce the most matches
i define my addressable market as the
world i was willing to move countries
or travel long distances to build my
career portfolio
jeffrey pfeffer says leaving california
is considered a radical move for most
stanford mbas
in contrast i was willing to go almost
anywhere
now being industry focused forced me to
have an international focus
because most airlines are spread over
all over the world
it required me to learn portuguese and
german and i became fluent in each
but there's a cost i remember sitting in
rio
at lunch time six months after joining
and i had tears in my eyes because the
ipo had been cooled off
and the brazilian economy was starting
to turn and i'd struggled to make
friends
i remember thinking to myself who moves
to brazil not knowing anyone
where hardly anyone speaks english
i want to imagine to imagine now that
you're back for a college reunion
how would you spend your one free day
would you explore the campus
buy presents from the gift shop meet an
old professor
meet a local startup or catch up with
your section mates
it's about being thoughtful in using
your time and thinking ahead
i'm going to give you some real examples
of how i did this
so first of all i'd like to encourage
you to be bold when i had that low point
in brazil
i decided i wanted to move back to
europe and i sent my cv
to six european airline ceos just out of
the blue
i didn't know them just said here's my
cv i mentioned the job
do you have anything
interestingly christophe franz had just
become ceo of lufthansa
and he responded
actually these days i'm even more
refined in my approach
and that if i wanted to do something
like that i would get one of my mentors
to send that email on my behalf
it's even more impactful if one ceo is
writing to another ceo and saying i
recommend this guy go speak to him
um the hit rate then drops to increases
to 100 percent
so when i achieved this platform of
joining lufthansa as
chief chief strategy officer
i realized that we had a partnership
with the world archiving forum
so i became the representative of
lufthansa to the world economic forum
through this i was invited to join one
of their global agenda councils for
travel
during this time i heard about a program
called the young global leaders which is
a program for around 100 people every
year under the age of 40
to join and participate in the work of
the forum and also attend the annual
meeting in davos
now before even getting involved with
this organization i hadn't even really
appreciated
the the significance of the annual
meeting at davos
also through my time at lufthansa i was
able to get on the boards
of three subsidiaries
i told you about this example of being
at a reunion thinking ahead i remember
being at one reunion
and meeting uh meeting a friend and
saying
i've got this body prior border
experience and i'd like now to
get on an external board maybe one of
your portfolio companies might have a
have an opening and he was a partner at
cvc
and uh he said leave it with him and um
introduced me to one of their portfolio
companies i had some interviews and
after a while i was offered a position
to join their board again
from just being at a reunion speaking to
someone i knew
and putting that out there i was able to
get
on this board
now the third pillar was stanford
so my journey to stanford um
i was actually just invited by the
hospitality and travel club
just to give a one-off speech about the
travel industry
i was there for three days and whilst i
was still down there i heard about
compressed classes and i thought wow
this fits perfectly
for a busy schedule so whilst i was
still down there
i met with the dean and developed a
proposal
to start the first ivy league mba
program
dedicated to travel and airline industry
the dean thought okay well let's try it
if it works we can keep it
if it doesn't we'll stop it this was
2014.
this class has been instrumental for me
in building my profile in the travel
industry
it's also given the opportunity to meet
travel industry ceos
um and bring them in every year one of
my heroes is david nieleman
and he's been joining the class every
year he's the founder of azul and
jetblue
so i've been able to use this class as a
calling card to bring in
travel industry veterans
as part of my time at stanford i asked
my friend who's the best professor that
you have
and he said jeffrey pfeffer
so every year when i've been going back
to teach i've had lunch
with jeffrey after five years of these
lunches
one day he said to me i'm thinking about
writing a new case study
and i'd like to make you the protagonist
jeffrey is now writing a book called the
seven new rules of power
and he's going to be featuring me in
this book
through all of these engagements at
stanford actually this is how i've been
invited to speak to you today
and to give you a real life example of
how i apply disciplined opportunism
i'm now thinking if this talk is a
success how can i apply it
to writing a book or developing a
podcast series
now in addition into these in these
activities
as part of my vision of being a role
model i also nominated myself to the
financial times top 100 leaders list
and was included on those lists forth
for three years in a row
i also got to meet the organizer of ted
in germany and in 2014 he invited me
to give the first airline ted talk so
i hope i share with you some really
practical examples there about how i was
able to create opportunities and use
one platform to open up another
let's now talk about within and within a
company how you can fill the void
within companies not all roles are
filled fill that void
figure out what the company needs to do
to win
and pursue it like it's never been
pursued before
so for example when i was at lufthansa
i recognized the importance of
innovation in digital
and i was able to convince the board to
allow me to build a team
to drive innovation and create an
innovation hub in berlin
at emirates there's no strategy function
but have been proactive at initiating
strategic dialogues
and providing a regular outlook on the
industry across the business
so pursue is all about being global in
your search being creative about
spotting opportunities
and filling the voids in companies
let's now look at partner the fourth p
the fourth p is all about relationships
inside a company in order to have impact
you need the support of colleagues
mentors and friends
and also to understand the power
dynamics in companies
there's a great quote from gandhi first
they ignore you
then they laugh at you then they fight
you then you win
and that's obviously with the support of
those around you
let's dive into a couple of areas around
power dynamics
and building promoters
at hbs i learned the 20 60 20 rule
that's 20 of people will be your
promoters
60 of people will be undecided and 20
of people will be your critics
so the first thing to think about is
understanding personal agendas
when it comes to critics they have their
own agenda
when i was doing consulting we always
told just to focus on results but moving
into a big corporate you start to
understand
people are very scared about change and
losing their positions
and driving change is um divisive
so the key is to identify and engage
your promoters
and get them to help you in influencing
those who are
undecided
the objective with critics is actually
just damage limitation
and not wasting too much energy with
them
and they are generally driven by
insecurities and in fact all the critics
i had
in my career often ended up leaving
quite early
because they were insecure in their
positions
another thing to think about is
identifying narcissists
either the charming types or the
dictator bullying types
they're very common in senior positions
in big companies because they're willing
to do whatever it takes to get ahead
and so you have to be able to identify
them and work with them
another thing to think about is ensuring
that your team has your back
otherwise it'll be like flying with the
full payload your speed and range will
be compromised
watch out for biases and recruiting
people similar to you you need a mix of
skills in your team
partnering is also true in our personal
lives who do you spend time with in your
free time that you can learn from
due to covet we've all had to be more
selective about the people we spend time
with
so when it comes to sensing power
dynamics another great quote from jung
things which irritate us in others can
lead us to an understanding of ourselves
and this works both ways
is there something you don't like about
someone that could be something that
they're able to demonstrate which is
something you're not comfortable about
in yourselves
and if they don't like you there's
something about you which is also
triggering a complex
the reason why i bring this up is this
is heavily about psychology and
understanding
power is understanding psychology
let's now look at how we can build
promoters
i like to ask yourself who's on your
personal advisory board
i'll ask you now just to think down the
names of three to five mentors or
advisors
who you would assemble to help you
prepare you for something like an
exciting new job opportunity
opportunity
ask yourself how often are you in
contact with them
who's your agile team that you can
assemble to solve problems
at stanford mba graduates you've got an
amazing network to tap into
if for example i have to give a speech
like this one
i'll um speak to my friends in the
industry
i actually tested the title for this
speech using an instagram poll
as an outsider joining lufthansa i
always joke that
it felt like joining a gamer monopoly
halfway through
just going around and giving money to
everyone with the hotels
through my experience at lufthansa i
learned eight tips
and i was able to learn a lot from ceos
how to build communication to build
partnerships
and especially from carson spor who's
the ceo of lufthansa
so the first tip is understand
personality types
we've talked about the myers-briggs or
jung type
typology understand what drives people
the second tip is to identify common
interests
and build bridges i remember casting
sport would say to me
we're both the young guys here when
we're in board meetings
the third tip is sharing articles and
regular updates
relationships should be two-way so if
you read something interesting share it
with those close in your network
give them regular updates of what's
going on in your life
and also the fourth point seek their
help
and the best is if you can become a
personal advisor to them and again
it's a two-way relationship and in order
to advance you need to meet regularly
and have a lot of contact
the fifth point is amplifying again i
learned this from karstenspor
he was great you would meet him in the
corridor and he would say to you oh mr
galani you're smiling
what numbers have you seen that i
haven't seen
he made people feel good and was always
smiling
it's also about empathizing and
again he is great at saying when he's
addressing an audience imagining the
flight attendant and
the work that they're doing creating
that image
another point which he's great at is
referencing and building upon others
in meetings ah mr galani you're always
the one that's saying that we should go
buy this company
also using metaphors
building upon prior experience that
you've had in your career or providing a
worse option
for example i could say to you
you can either share this talk with your
friends
or ignore everything and fail in your
careers now these are not too like for
like options but providing a worse
option
can influence people towards another
option
and the last tip is summarizing any
actions or takeaways from the meeting
both one-on-one meetings
and in group settings the shows you've
been listening
and takes control of the messages coming
out of the meeting
again these are eight practical tips for
building relationships
and our partners and allies are really
important to us and it can help you
fly higher however things don't always
go according to plan
it's not about liking or disliking your
colleagues it's about trying to make
critical relationships work
but sometimes these are outside of your
control
and that's where the fifth p comes in
pivot
when you reach cruising altitude switch
on the autopilot enjoy the view out the
window
but be prepared for turbulence
great quote from steve jobs pursue your
dreams and see the opportunities in life
setbacks
when you get your life to cruising
altitude everything starts flowing
automatically
but something unexpected can happen
requiring adaptability
patience resilience and reinvention
and a question for you how many of your
bosses left the company after hiring
hiring you
now this is important because when
supervisors leave
it generally a supervisor rates the
people they hired much
higher than inherited employees so if a
boss leaves that is a big deal
i'd like to now go and take you through
a crucible
moment
crystal franz when i joined lufthansa
had brought in five senior leaders from
outside to bring in fresh ideas
under his leadership i received the
highest performance rating of any stp
and initiate a profit improvement
program which is credited with turning
around the company
however there's a quote here from the
german media that said
friends in the past two years brought in
specialists from outside on whose
loyalty can count on
this includes me and the rather
cumbersome and highly german business
swirling around with ideas that
traditionalists must consider in a front
just to set the context
however three years later in april 2014
christopher franz announced he would be
leaving to become chairman of rush and
his rival carson spore would be taking
over
i had a crucible moment at his leaving
party when i got the call that my father
had passed away
my mother had developed alzheimer's
shortly thereafter and as the only child
i had to take care of her
this article came out again in the
german media people who know spore
well believe that there will be no major
people moves with one exception
no one expects strategies to deed gilani
to remain
france appointed gilani in order to
shake things up gilani had done this
intensively
more than most people liked spore
included
this shows you the importance of
promoters it was actually my mentor
who convinced my new boss to keep me
three months later the german media
reported
the question of whom spa will appoint in
top rolls is closely watched
and the new ceo knows this that's why
there's one thing he does not do
the thing that everyone expects from him
his chief strategy officer
may continue to develop new concepts on
the other hand many of sport's allies
await their next career step
so from this point in time after three
years with lufthansa i was able to stay
on for two more years
working as chief strategy offer for cast
and sport and then two years
moving into eurowings
moving to eurowings was an interesting
move for me
was moving into a fast-growing
subsidiary and into the core of the
airline
which was managing network and fleet in
some ways it was a bit of step down
but i was focused on learning and had a
long-term perspective
so you have to work extra hard to
impress someone who's inherited you
and also be patient there's a quote from
roomie
patient is not sitting and waiting it's
foreseeing
it's looking at the thorn and seeing the
rose looking at the night and seeing the
day
know that the moon needs time to become
full
i enjoyed spa expanding from being an
airline guy to a travel industry guy
through this time through my work with
the wef
through stanford and my board positions
we can start getting exposure to new
domains by many avenues
like boards universities
mentoring startups or investing
so think about what's in your portfolio
there's ways to start now
getting access and building that
portfolio
so that was the final p pivot and covert
has required many of us to adapt our
flight path
it's also healthy to reinvent yourself
every decade
so you stay fresh and relevant
if you feel that your career has
plateaued this is a good chance to think
about pivoting to an adjacent field
if you're later in your career it may be
time to start thinking about
what your retirement portfolio might
look like and start pivoting there
for a soft landing
i started early looking for opportunity
to build relevant experience to expand
my portfolio
leveraging the platforms which i had but
i also created the space to pursue them
so this was an overview of how i applied
discipline opportunism in my life
to build my portfolio career
let's now pivot and apply the same 5p
framework
to the travel and airline industry
so i'm going to start by asking you what
do you think we're most likely to
experience
in travel in 2022
do you think we can experience higher
ticket prices
fewer non-stop flight options
less relevance of loyalty programs
pcr testing required before flying
or most countries still close to
visitors
you can think about multiple of these
as we know go through i'll give you some
insight into all of these topics
the first thing when it comes to purpose
is travel purposes are changing
unfortunately travel is going to remain
a hassle with pcr tests and masks likely
to remain with us for some time
most travelers will still be concerned
with limiting exposure to people in the
coming years
preparing beach and outdoor destinations
travelers are thinking carefully about
their first vaccinations
that's the first vacation people will
take after being vaccinated
i personally am most keen to go back to
thailand
i spent my first decade in my 19 in my
20s
adding new countries wanting to reach
100 countries before the age of 30.
since then i prefer going back to places
i like where i have memories where i
know the best spots
and i have friends
when it comes to travel our minds are
reminiscent
enjoying returning to the familiar
but they're also comparative setting the
baseline as the best
of all previous experiences for our
enjoyment
because of this hassle of pcr tests
we will take longer but fewer trips
an average of nine days versus four days
in the past
we will also be more purposeful and
meaningful about selecting our travel
experiences
we expect leisure and visiting friends
and relatives as a type of travel to
come back first
people will have a higher disposable
income for travel spend be willing to
upgrade
their experiences and splurge more on
luxury
on the other hand there's going to be a
reduction in business travel
mckinsey are projecting a 20 long-term
reduction in business travel
for example through the reduction of day
trips
and because airlines and hotels make the
majority of their profits on these
travelers this
is very disruptive
we're also seeing an erosion of the
middle with trips booked either
last minute within seven days or well in
advance more than 365 days in advance
lastly the topic of sustainability is
becoming more relevant so for example
google is just getting way to show the
flight emissions
in google flights to help nudge people
towards choosing flights
which have lower emissions so for
example if you're thinking about a
business
class flight that's going to show three
times as many emissions as an economy
flight
and a non-stop option will show far
fewer emissions than a connecting flight
forward-thinking travel companies have
already spotted the opportunity to take
a leading role in sustainability
and embedding in that as part of their
mission even in the middle of a pandemic
this is how i personally have been
driving at lufthansa and emirates as
well
to give you some examples of what the
industry is doing
jetblue in the us has now made all of
the domestic u.s flights
carbon neutral the owner of british
airways
iag is committed to powering 10 of its
flights with sustainable aviation fuel
by 2030
carnival cruises is targeting a 40
reduction
in emissions by 2030
so that's purpose and to say travel
purposes are changing stability is
becoming more important
the second p of prepare is to say the
industry is preparing
like it's never had before and winners
will emerge
the industry has responded through
permanently retiring older aircraft
especially older four engine wide bodies
which will mean fewer non-stop options
airlines are also adapting their product
to a post-covered world
for example at emirates we're offering
customers free code insurance
removing change in cancellation fees
increasing cabin cleaning
and most of our crew are vaccinated at
the same time
we've introduced the first biometric
contactless airport experience in dubai
but a big issue for the airline industry
is there's a huge debt burden now
the average debt burn of the industry
will double
and has doubled by the end of the
pandemic
and it was going to take us until 2030
to repay that debt
using the free cash flow which we're
generating pre-crisis
now winners are made during the time of
a crisis
geographically u.s airlines will emerge
stronger due to having a strong domestic
market
high government support and strong
returns going into the crisis
in contrast european airlines and
emerging market network carriers
will be the worst off low-cost airlines
will emerge stronger
due to reliance on short-haul leisure
flying
and airlines with the strongest balance
sheets
like south delta and emirates
would emerge as winners
for example delta strategy pre-code of
flying mostly
older aircraft which is quite unique
meant that they have been able to ground
or retire 40
of their fleet during the pandemic
without major write-offs
unlike any of their peers they can now
benefit from replacing those older
aircraft with newer aircraft in a
depressed market
now that is discipline opportunism
and it's interesting that 40 airlines
have gone out of business since covert
began
and an additional 10 airlines went into
bankruptcy protection to restructure
but this is a tiny fraction out of the
thousand airlines which are out there
and at the same time as airlines are
exiting other airlines and entrepreneurs
are thinking about pursuing this market
so that brings us to pursue and we're
seeing disruptors
preparing for takeoff
we've seen an unprecedented number of
startups gearing up to enter the
the aviation market and actually it's
greater than the number of exits almost
twice
as many entrance new entrance startups
coming in as exited the market
now covert is triggering that because
that's created excess aircraft it's
created slots
and it's curated gaps in the market
we're also seeing new technologies
around aerial mobility using spax
that's special purpose acquisition
companies raising billions
with just a business plan
now one thing we're seeing is that it's
a challenge for airlines to ramp up
given the investment backlog they have
they haven't been spending anything to
preserve cash for the last two years and
they have this debt overhang on top
which is going to lead to a long ramp up
and an under supply of airline capacity
relative to demand which is actually
going to rebound strongly particularly
on the leisure side
now this is in contrast the relative
oversupply of hotel rooms and cruise
cabins
so expect higher flight ticket prices in
the coming years
but you'll be able to get bargains on
hotel rooms and cruises
it's also interesting that the demand
for alternative accommodation
such as airbnb continues to grow year on
year
and even during the pandemic it has been
growing
partly due to things like remote working
which is likely to continue
so many uh players within the aviation
industry
are seeing the crisis as an opportunity
to pursue
we're also players players are also
thinking about partnerships
in different ways this pandemic has
required the travel industry to work
together like never before
to coordinate and support the reopening
of travel through initiatives for
example such as the yata travel pass
partnerships are becoming even more
important for airlines because they have
smaller networks
players are also thinking more about
system collaboration between
airports and ground for example we're
seeing air rail brickings being
able to be booked in one ticket
many uh transport companies are thinking
about becoming super apps
for example lime is trying to become a
platform which are enabled to be
you to book multiple forms of mobility
partners are also thinking about adding
capabilities outside of their core
business so for example
many travel players are talking about
end-to-end travel booking.com wants to
expand from just offering
hotels and alternative accommodation to
also offering flights
but they've chose to do that by
partnering
with a company called etravali which is
the best in the industry
flight search platform rather than do it
themselves
so partnerships becoming more relevant
and
many travel players are really thinking
about pivoting in light of the pandemic
european airlines in particular as i
said are going to be the ones to
struggle the most
and they're pivoting their business more
towards leisure because as i said that's
going to come back first and they'll be
less
fewer business rubbers we're also seeing
that
challenged airlines who were struggling
for profitability even before covid
are reviewing their business models so
for example norwegian has now ended
long-haul flying
hotels are also looking to launch new
products such as work from anywhere
and they're also looking at wellness
programs to try and compensate for some
of the lost business
traffic
i also believe frequent frequent
traveler programs for hotels and
airlines
are going to struggle to become relevant
and they're going to have to accelerate
the pivot towards becoming consumer
loyalty businesses which were started
before covert
meaning appealing to a broader range of
people beyond just people who are flying
often or traveling often
one way to do that is to include credit
card spend as part of
status recognition so don't worry just
yet about losing your frequent travel
status
we're also seeing an interesting
opportunity around
regional aircraft being converted to
hydrogen propulsion to be
efficient and and green there's a great
example of surfer
which originally was a private aviation
california-based membership club
it took the first step of pivoting to
becoming a platform
to book private jets it's now pivoting
again
to become surf air mobility and it's
pursuing regional aircraft conversions
to to enable regional aircraft to
convert to hydrogen power
and again it's an amazing pivot at this
time as this technology now becomes
proven
to be able to change their their
business again
so the main message is that players in
the travel and airline industry
are being forced to adapt their business
models for a turbulent post-covered
world
travel volumes are likely to take until
2024 to return
so in closing i hope that you took away
some practical ideas to fast track your
career
and you've got a glimpse of what's to
come in travel in the coming years
i hope that i inspired you to apply the
art of disciplined opportunism
by being clear on your purpose by
preparing your mind body and soul
by being alert to pursue
by having the right partners to support
you and
by pivoting to adapt to new situations
remember that we put ourselves through
permanent career comparison by going
through an mba
so at times of reunions we should be
careful of falling into that trap
my career success came from taking
advantage of opportunities which came up
which were aligned to my purpose
and which i had the time to pursue so
create that space
start thinking now about how you want
your portfolio career to look like
i'll leave you with one quote from
roomie yesterday i was clever so i
wanted to change the world
today i'm wise i'm changing myself
this also reflects a bit what carl jung
said about there being two phases of
life and the second phase of life
being around individuation and looking
inner
to close if you've enjoyed what you've
heard today
i'll be sharing more tips and
recommended reading on the art of
disciplinary opportunism
on my linkedin page and on instagram
please follow me for more tips
also if you've enjoyed this talk today
please share it with your friends once
it's published on youtube
thank you
[Applause]